Una área donde la computación cuántica podría mejorar el aprendizaje automático
está relacionada con las funciones kernel o
las matrices kernel. Veamos qué son
y por qué las necesitamos. Para eso, recordaremos
tres cosas: por qué aparecen los productos punto en el aprendizaje automático,
por qué los problemas de aprendizaje automático involucran dimensiones más altas,
y qué son las funciones kernel.
Recuerda que el producto punto o producto interno de
vectores reales de n dimensiones a
y b está dado por el producto de la magnitud de a,
la magnitud de b y el coseno del ángulo theta,
el ángulo entre ellos. Esto es equivalente a multiplicar
cada componente de a por el componente correspondiente de
b y sumarlos. Ten en cuenta que si los vectores son
casi ortogonales, como cuando a
tiene componentes nulas donde b tiene componentes grandes,
el producto punto es pequeño. Esto equivale a que
theta se acerque a pi sobre dos.
De forma similar, si a tiene componentes negativas donde b
tiene componentes positivas,
es decir, los vectores apuntan en
direcciones casi opuestas
y theta está cerca de pi,
el resultado del producto punto podría ser
negativo. Por último, si a tiene componentes grandes donde b
también tiene componentes grandes del mismo signo,
es decir, los vectores son casi paralelos y theta está cerca de cero,
el producto punto será grande
y positivo. Así que es muy razonable esperar que los productos punto
sean una medida de similitud útil
entre puntos de datos. No todos los datos de n dimensiones
se pueden separar fácilmente con un corte de n menos
una dimensión, es decir, una línea,
un plano o un hiperplano. Cuando los datos no están bien separados
en n dimensiones, podemos incrustar los puntos de datos
en dimensiones más altas, digamos m dimensiones, donde m
es mayor que n. Esto se llama mapeo de características,
que suele denotarse como x yendo a phi(x), donde
phi(x) es un mapeo de los reales de n dimensiones a los
reales de m dimensiones.
Es más fácil visualizarlo
al doblar un conjunto de datos unidimensionales hacia
dos dimensiones, o tomar datos bidimensionales
e incrustarlo en tres dimensiones.
Pero en la práctica, a menudo incrustamos datos en espacios con miles
o incluso millones de dimensiones.
Un producto punto de vectores tridimensionales comparado con un producto
punto de vectores bidimensionales es una diferencia insignificante.
Pero un producto punto de vectores de un millón de dimensiones
se vuelve completamente intratable
para aplicarlo a un conjunto de datos grande.
Así que la gente inventó un truco ingenioso:
¿qué pasaría si usaras una proyección
hacia dimensiones más altas con una forma muy específica,
de modo que los productos punto de los vectores en
dimensiones más altas sean una función simple de los
vectores de menor dimensión? Es decir, encontrar un mapeo
de nuestros datos x a phi(x) de mayor dimensión,
tal que el producto interno en el
espacio de características esté dado por una
función simple en los datos de menor dimensión.
Esta función k se llama función kernel.
Idealmente, queremos que esta función kernel
sea una función del producto interno de
menor dimensión en sí mismo. Eso nos daría lo mejor de ambos mundos:
un espacio de características de muy alta dimensión,
pero con un producto interno barato y fácil de calcular.
A primera vista, puede que no
sea obvio que esto sea posible. Veamos
un ejemplo simple en dimensiones muy bajas.
Considera este mapeo de características específico: mapea un
vector tridimensional a un
espacio de nueve dimensiones. Resulta
que el producto interno del espacio de características de nueve dimensiones
está dado simplemente por el producto interno en el
espacio 3D original, elevado al cuadrado. Así que el producto interno
del espacio mapeado usando las funciones phi
requeriría calcular cada una de las
nueve coordenadas del
primer vector y nueve del
segundo, y luego el producto interno en sí, que son
otros nueve productos y una suma:
un total de veintiocho operaciones.
La función kernel requiere tres productos
y dos sumas, lo que corresponde a solo cuatro operaciones.
Eso fue para mapear un punto de datos tridimensional a un
espacio de características de nueve dimensiones.
Es fácil ver que esto podría ser muy ventajoso
para espacios de muy alta dimensión.
La función kernel es típicamente una función continua
que puedes aplicar a cualquier vector de tu conjunto de datos.
Pero usamos las funciones kernel tomando
pares de puntos de datos de nuestro conjunto
como argumentos. Aplicar una función kernel a
cada par de puntos de datos del conjunto
da como resultado una matriz simétrica llamada la matriz
kernel. El tipo de función kernel que usarás depende de
tu problema. Entonces, para recapitular:
describir la similitud de los vectores en nuestros conjuntos de datos
a menudo requiere productos internos. Los productos internos en
espacios de características de muy alta dimensión se vuelven costosos,
así que usamos mapeos de características que corresponden
a ciertas funciones kernel especiales
que hacen el cálculo más eficiente.
Pero esta restricción a funciones kernel especiales
limita qué tipos de mapeos al espacio de características
se pueden hacer de forma eficiente. Esto
puede impedirnos separar bien nuestros datos.
Ojalá hubiera otra manera.
Aquí es donde entra la computación cuántica.
El mapeo de características de muy alta dimensión correspondiente
a las funciones kernel puede llevarse a cabo
en una computadora cuántica. En el estimador kernel cuántico,
la matriz kernel k se calcula
y a partir de ahí se puede usar un algoritmo clásico de aprendizaje automático.
Para lograrlo, un punto de datos x uno
se carga y se mapea, y luego
se carga otro, x dos,
y también se mapea. Como el producto interno de dos estados cuánticos
está relacionado con la probabilidad de medición,
podemos estimar el producto interno de los dos puntos de datos mapeados
haciendo suficientes mediciones del
circuit resultante. De esta manera, nuestro circuit
puede darnos información sobre un producto interno
en cualquier espacio de alta dimensión que el circuit pueda modelar,
sin que nunca calculemos clásicamente un producto interno o una
función kernel. Hay muchas formas de
personalizar y mejorar estos métodos,
y de hecho siempre se están proponiendo nuevos métodos
y poniéndolos a prueba. Esperamos que este
resumen haya sido útil para enmarcar la
aplicación de la computación cuántica
a los métodos de aprendizaje automático,
especialmente aquellos que involucran kernels.